bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est Andrée c'est un ancien membre du
groupe paramilitaire russe Wagner dirigé
par yves-gagny près et gaugine le 13
janvier dernier il a franchi
clandestinement la frontière entre la
Russie et la Norvège il est avec nous
depuis Oslo merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous
bonjour
quand vous êtes recruté en juillet 2022
vous êtes envoyé très vite en
Ukraine
vous êtes dans l'Est notamment dans la
province de denies et vous décidez
quelques mois plus tard en novembre de
fuir que s'est-il passé pourquoi avoir
pris cette décision
le comportement du commandement leur
méthode
de contrainte de gens de contraindre des
soldats qui ne voulaient pas aller au
combat et ça l'est jusqu'au
exécutions et les ordres aussi les
ordres qui étaient des ordres
idiots qui n'étaient pas des ordres
réfléchi
il y avait une absence de
[Musique]
soins ou deux
d'envie de protéger les soldats c'était
vraiment de la chair à canon
et que beaucoup d'autres aspects qui
étaient dans le même sens sans aucun
égard enfin si je donnais le détail et
bien j'en aurai pour des jours quand
vous décidez de fuir c'est quand même
une décision grave parce que on sait que
le groupe Wagner réserve un sort parfois
extrêmement violent à ceux qui fuient
est-ce que vous étiez au courant de ce
qui arrivait à ceux qui sont considérés
comme des fuyards ou des traîtres quand
ils sont membres de Wagner
la zone de l'opération militaire
spéciale et dans la majorité des cas ils
étaient arrêtés et les conséquences
étaient terrifiantes
chacun misait le tout pour le tout et là
j'ai pris ma décision j'avais depuis
longtemps d'hésiter de ce genre
quand on commence à se rendre compte de
ce qui se passe on n'a plus envie de
rester là et de respecter les ordres et
de respecter des gens qui vous
traite avec cet arbitraire
et puis un moment j'ai décidé
et c'était dur bien sûr
mais j'ai quand même réussi à prendre
cette décision à elle fait vous étiez au
courant de ce qui est arrivé à un
certain efghani new Jin qui a été tué
avec avec une masse une exécution qui a
été filmée et rendu public par Wagner
justement
d'un grand nombre d'autres cas qui se
sont produits
suite à des tentatives de fuite
[Musique]
refusait d'exécuter des autres mais je
n'avais pas de choix et j'aurais très
bien pu être les deux
et je comprends très bien ce qui aurait
pu se produire mais j'ai
réuni mes forces et ma volonté j'ai fait
ce pas
est-ce que vous avez été témoin direct
de gens qui comme vous ont voulu partir
et qui ont été exécutés je parle de
témoignages directs est-ce que vous avez
vu des gens de Wagner exécutés on parle
beaucoup du service de sécurité interne
de Wagner dans ce genre d'opération
d'un grand nombre de choses
je ne peux pas parler de
choses qui me sont arrivées
personnellement
[Musique]
est-ce que donc vous avez aussi été
témoin de des actions contre les
populations civiles en Ukraine mais vous
ne voulez pas en parler c'est ça
je n'ai vu aucun cas
permettent des actions
mauvaise vis-à-vis de la population il y
a eu des cas au sein du commandement
et là je pourrais donner un témoignage
mais de la part des des hommes non
donc ce que vous dites c'est que des
personnes haut placées dans la
hiérarchie de Wagner ont commis des
crimes en Ukraine que vous avez vu ou
dont vous avez eu témoignage
je donnerai des témoignages
sur
ces faits quand le moment sera venu
donner un témoignage mais je ne peux pas
répondre maintenant à une question toute
simple comme la vôtre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
c'était dans un centre de formation
dans l'un des centres de formation
et je venais faire une formation
[Musique]
donc il est venu
voir ses anciens détenus il les a mis en
rang il a prononcé des discours disant
que nous étions les meilleurs que les
autres sont des il disait que
makmout avait déjà été conquis et que il
restait à entrer tout simplement
et là j'ai dit mon avis dans cette
situation
que il suffit d'y entrer mais qu'elle va
être le prix
et là
ça s'est terminé plutôt mal comment elle
s'est comment elle s'est terminée pour
vous
j'ai une longue discussion avec notre
chef de groupe
et on m'a mis dans un container pendant
quelques temps et puis ensuite on va
lancer de nouveau au combat
pourquoi parce que vous n'étiez pas
d'accord avec ce que vous disais-je
gagner Prigogine c'est ça
de ma vraie opinion pour moi
je vous en parle pour que vous me
racontiez en effet ce qui s'est passé
mais c'est aussi parce qu'on le voit de
plus en plus
publiquement sur le terrain dans les
médias avant tout autour de barmouth
il critique d'ailleurs le manque de
soutien
de l'armée russe il dit qu'il n'a pas
assez de munitions il dénonce il dénonce
à quoi joue-t-il parce que on a
l'impression que parfois il conteste
l'autorité des de l'armée russe
je regarde
ces vidéos je regarde toutes ces
publications je suis étonné de voir
comment les citoyens russes qui sont
contre
les opérations en
Ukraine ils sont condamnés parce que ils
que l'omnie l'armée russe je ne
comprends pas pourquoi pourquoi il ne
condamne pas
pris goji une parce que trigogine a été
particulièrement insultant et
contre l'armée russe donc et son
comportement pour être très franc et je
l'ai toujours dit
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui est malade qui ne sait pas
ce qu'il fait il a l'impression que tout
lui ait permis
j'ai l'impression que à la fin de ce
théâtre qui est en train de se produire
il va être liquidé par ses propres
hommes
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
obéit à Vladimir Poutine ou que il a
cessé de lui obéir
à Vladimir Poutine
il ne serait plus là s'il n'obéissait
pas c'était une c'est une rue tout
simple on ne peut pas
être en Russie et agir comme il le fait
parmi les plus hautes élites sans être
obéissant
Andreï Metz vedef pour terminer pour les
Ukrainiens
en tant que ancien membre de ma Wagner
même si vous avez fui vous êtes sans
doute un criminel et il ne faudrait pas
que la Norvège vous accorde l'asile quel
est votre réaction à leur sentiment à 26
ans moi j'ai compris et ça a été quelque
chose de
déterminant quand j'ai entendu c'est
civil qui
comportement
leur courage c'est ça qui a déterminé
mon action ma prise de risque je
voudrais dire au peuple crinien que je
demande pardon de la part que j'ai prise
mais je demanderai à tous les Ukrainiens
de ne pas haïr le peuple russe les
Russes
des gens bien ils sont simplement
victimes de la propagande ils ont été
élevés et
instruire
le peuple le peuple russe ne sait pas
réuni sur une grande place comme un seul
homme pour décider d'aller en masse
conquérir l'Ukraine cette
individus qui ont pris ces décisions
mais les gens ont leur a lavé la
cervelle et ce sont les autorités qui
sont derrière tout cela pas le peuple
j'ai tout dit dernière question André
Metz
vous êtes donc en Norvège vous avez
demandé l'asile je sais que vous vous
avez rendez-vous avec la justice pour un
pour un récentes incident est-ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes en sécurité en
Norvège et que vous allez pouvoir
obtenir l'asile
je ne pense plus à rien advienne que
pour un s'il me donne l'asile et bien ce
sera bien sinon je vais essayer de
trouver d'autres voies et s'il m'envoie
en Russie et puis un jour viendra en
Russie avec la vérité que j'ai
conquise et je suis prêt à affronter le
sort qui m'attend très bien merci
beaucoup André Yvette d'avoir répondu
aux questions de France 24 depuis
Oslo merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes restez-y pour
plus d'informations
[Musique]